bienvenue à tous paris saclay le mag
c'est votre nouveau rendez vous sur ce
site unique en france un site qui innove
qui change
nous allons vous pouvez dans les arcanes
de ce lieu à suivre dans un instant les
précisions de son directeur général
guillaume pasquier alors paris saclay
est dédié à la recherche à la formation
alors pour favoriser les échanges
il faut savoir sortir des sentiers
battus vous verrez comment le proto 204
permet de réunir des scientifiques des
étudiants mais aussi des habitants
autour d'événements comme le retro
gaming
enfin paris saclay c'est aussi des
chantiers des chantiers d'envergure
c'est ici qu'il y aura le futur edf
laddh qui sera le premier centre de
recherche et de formation du groupe en
europe et enfin vous saurez tout du
synchrotron soleil et de ses lignes de
lumière
des scientifiques viennent du monde
entier pour nous tuer nous voici donc
sur un site unique en france et même en
europe c'est un projet scientifique
économique et en bas qui se développe
depuis 50 ans alors comment être
performants et innovants
nous sommes allés poser la question à
guillaume pasquier le directeur général
de l'établissement public paris saclay
le plateau de saclay c'est ce vaste
territoire au sud ouest de paris
bien connue parce qu'il est l'un des
grands poumon vert de la région
ile-de-france à 15 km du sud de paris un
territoire agricole verts entourés par
une ceinture d'urbanisation depuis une
cinquantaine d'années se sont installés
sur ce périmètre assez petit en réalité
à peu près 15 à 20% de la recherche r&d
publiques et privées françaises donc des
grandes institutions de recherche très
connu de tous le cnrs l'inra le cea des
grands établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche l'université
paris-sud l'école polytechnique hec
l'université versailles saint quentin et
des grands centres de r&d d'ingénierie
des grandes entreprises renault thalès
danone eads sont ici et tout ça fait un
an semble absolument exceptionnel unique
en france ça c'est certain
probablement unique en europe par ses
potentiels
l'ambition c'est simplement de prendre
acte de ces potentiels et d'en tirer le
maximum de faire en sorte que tout cela
rayonne et créer un moteur un moteur de
croissance de développement d'économie
de création d'emplois de création de
richesse au service de cette partie de
la france mais plus largement du grand
paris est sans doute de la france
entière puisque on a ici en réalité la
capacité de créer l'une des dix grandes
plateformes d'innovation au monde
l'un des endroits attractif pour tous
ceux qui ont des idées qui veulent créer
qui veulent développer et qui est qui
regardent ces lieux d'agrégation ces
lieux où se passent les choses est la
raison d'être de ce projet c'est cessez
donc l'innovation et donc il s'adresse
en premier lieu à tous les acteurs de
l'innovation
mais il faut aller plus loin il faut
penser à tous à tous les techniciens
qualifiés plus ou moins qualifiés et kit
qui travaille ensuite dans ces secteurs
il faut penser à tous les étudiants et
même j'ai envie de dire aux futurs
étudiants à ceux qui ont envie de faire
de la science de faire de la technologie
donc il faut qu'ils trouveront là j'ai
envie de dire un terrain de jeu
formidable pour développer leurs idées
rencontre et se croiser des talents
différents et être créatif tous ensemble
ce développement cette croissance elle
s'incarne par la recherche de réponses à
des grands défis sociétaux qui se pose
aujourd'hui dans le monde
ce sans doute probablement en partie
dans le projet paris saclay on trouvera
des éléments de réponse à des grands
défis que sont le réchauffement
climatique les maladies
neurodégénératives l'alimentation de 9
milliards d'êtres humains
la question de l'énergie propre la
question des déplacements etc etc
ici vont se trouver vont s'imaginer des
solutions avec la recherche amont et
puis la transition vers la recherche
avaler vers des solutions technologiques
qui sont à disposition du grand public
on vous emmène maintenant au proto 204
un lieu très récent qui vient tout juste
d'être inauguré l'objectif est de
favoriser les échanges dans une ambiance
détendue ludique
la preuve en images
le poteau 204 services mutualisés c'est
à dire la création et l'innovation la
formation sur le campus paris saclay est
notamment liée au croisement des
communautés chercheurs entrepreneurs
étudiants industriels et les habitants
après l'inauguration il ya deux semaines
on a une remise des prix la semaine
dernière autour du concours mobilité de
le pps s'il y avait donc les lauréats
des les six équipes lauréates du
concours
aujourd'hui on est très heureux
d'accueillir un autre type d'événement
qu'il y ait par l'association à poils
qui travaille sur les jeux vidéo est
donc là ils ont rassemblé tous leurs
leur rétro gaming c'est à dire des jeux
vidéo des années 90 qui ont redécouvert
puisque même était allé à l'époque et
donc ils se retrouvent ici pour un pour
s'affronter sur ces plateformes de
cession à poil devant aider sur le
campus d'orsay à paris sudre alors on
est très contents qu'ils puissent venir
ici en tant qu'usagers du campus est
donc directement des ag du lieu
ce qui nous intéressait dans leurs
événements cette notion de retrogaming
c'est à dire de faire des jeux vidéo
et pas sur les versions hd donc à votre
qualité actuelle mais vraiment de
reprendre les anciennes consoles donc là
en l'occurrence et les premières
playstation et les messes pour la
nintendo donc à des patrons qui ont plus
de 20 ans et qui se sont plu à gicler
personnes qui sont qui joue dessus et
double à ce plaisir de jouer super de se
retrouver et puis d'avoir des tournois
ou des événements ludiques pour les uns
pour les novices on a beaucoup aimé
cette notion-là de à de faire quelque
chose de manière simple et de croiser à
croiser les publics
le projet paris saclay c'est aussi des
chantiers d'envergure comme celui qui se
situe juste derrière moi celui d'edf lab
c'est la première fois que le groupe
construit de recherche et de formation
d'une telle envergure
il va devenir le premier centre
industriel de recherche et de formation
d'europe
il doit ouvrir ses portes en 2015
jean-paul chabar le directeur du projet
centre de recherche nous en dit plus
il s'agit d'un projet qu'on a appelés et
df nab paris saclay c'est un projet qui
illustre en fait les deux piliers de
développement du groupe pdf avec d'une
part le développement des compétences et
l'autre pilier et la recherche et
l'innovation puisque sur le site dont
vous voyez le chantier derrière vous
vous allez avoir à la fois un centre de
formation qui va être le premier centre
de formation ddf en europe est également
le plus grand centre de recherche et
développement du groupe nous a attirés
ici c'est la capacité de recherche et
d'innovation que va constituer demain le
regroupement de centres de recherche
publics et d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche de premier plan c'est la
première fois qu'on construit un site de
cette envergure est sûre tous c'est une
première au sens où on rapproche la
formation et la recherche et
développement de façon à développer les
synergies entre ces deux fonctions qui
constitue pour nous également une
première c'est de s'implanter sur un
campus scientifique et technique de
cette ampleur-là avec le regroupement de
l'ensemble des établissements qui vont
constituer l'université paris saclay on
aura un des dix premiers campus mondial
et ça bien sûr c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait unique va accueillir ici des
populations extrêmement diverses
d'abord sur le site de la recherche et
développement ils ont à la fois les
chercheurs et des f
mais aussi des chercheurs du monde
académique des thésards des stagiaires
de tout ça va se mettre en place au
travers d'un ensemble architectural qui
permettra au travers de bâtiments situés
en zones ouvertes c'est-à-dire sans
contrôle d'accès d'avoir une interaction
forte entre les populations
la réussite de paris saclay elle viendra
justement du transfert vers le marché
d'un certain nombre d'innovations qui
naîtront dans les laboratoires
académiques et quelque part la recherche
industrielle et une sorte de passeur
entre les résultats du monde académique
et puis les métiers soient les métiers
dans l'est dans les grands groupes
soient le marché donc je pense que on
aura demain sur paris saclay l'ensemble
des ingrédients pour faire en sorte que
la mayonnaise prenne et que la réussite
économique l'essor économique soit au
rendez-vous de campus de paris saclay
gros plan sur le s'accroître au soleil
ce centre scientifique basée sur le
plateau de saclay attire le chercheur du
monde entier pour sa haute technologie
ils peuvent faire des expériences
exceptionnelles grâce aux lignes de
lumière ces rayonnements permettre
d'analyser aussi bien des antiquités que
des enzymes et ce ne sont pas les idées
qui manquent
aline scientifique alors comment ça
marche et pour quelle finalité
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
vous êtes dans un instant de rayonnement
synchrotron ont utilisé l'écran as
online comme dans la plupart des 150 ans
dans le monde qui sont accélérées à de
très grandes vitesses
il ya des vitesses qui sont relativement
proches de la vitesse la limite il
propriété de ce faisceau d'électrons qui
circulent à grande vitesse c'est que si
on les perturbe par un champ magnétique
par exemple qui vont émettre une lumière
extrêmement intense d'un grand domaine
spectral qui pauvres et aux ixus coûte
très grande longueur d'onde infrarouge
est un des cas où les ondes
millimétriques étant également faisant
partie de ses lumières qui sont novices
de synchrotron accueille les lignes de
lumière
aucune ligne de lumière c'est un
laboratoire qui va exploiter cette
lumière dans une gamme d'énergie ou de
fréquence qui est particulière à un
objet scientifique ou un but
scientifique
une analyse une diffraction des rayons x
du rayonnement disent ils de rien on est
rapide et ougrée amant qui n'est pas
visible informe la puissance des
faisceaux la précision des faisceaux que
nous avons ici nous permet d'avoir des
détails et des analystes beaucoup
beaucoup plus précises qu'on peut avoir
à l'hôpital par exemple en tomographie
on aura des contrastes ils seront dix à
cent fois meilleurs
je suis le responsable de sa ligne de
lumière qui s'appelle approximer au
synchrotron soleil qui en ligne de
lumière qui est dédié à étudier les
structures des molécules biologiques en
forme cristallin dans le cas de ma ligne
proxima on se ramasse les rayons x qui
sort du saint coran on les focalise avec
des éléments des miroirs on choisit
l'énergie de nos rayons x et on les
amène vers un échantillon qui est les
champions conseils d'étudier il ya une
émergence d'idées de technologies qui
permettent des avancées
donc on est tous dans la recherche de
l'avancée scientifique qui est la plus
probante à soleil par exemple nous avons
deux équipes
bien sûr les équipes de chercheurs sont
la preuve que la lumière nous avons
aussi une équipe de chercheurs de
physiciens de lacs des accélérateurs qui
tous les jours et émettre des idées
nouvelles pour faire des faisceaux
d'électrons des des arrangements de
système magnétique qui vont nous
permettre d'obtenir des lumières
beaucoup puissant beaucoup plus petit et
nous derrière pourra l'exploiter pour
aller plus loin
on vient de le voir paris saclay s'étant
parmi les autres chantiers en cours ou
les nouveaux laboratoires de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau
la première pierre a été posée le 23
avril
si nous vous laboratoires permettront de
développer la recherche en physique en
déca deslisle en biologie en
météorologie
alors pourquoi une telle extension il ya
tout simplement pour attirer les
meilleurs étudiants la concurrence
mondiale étant féroce quelques
informations en bresse avant de nous
quitter
16 au 20 juin le proto 204 vous invite à
participer au festival mondial futur en
seine le 3 juillet c'est le paris saclay
invest événements qui se déroulent à
linstar paristech c'est à palaiseau une
journée des changes
une journée pour convaincre et
développer son réseau dix entreprises
innovantes seront présentés à des
investisseurs et aux acteurs socio
économiques du territoire
et voilà c'est déjà la fin de ce premier
paris saclay le mag
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt pour l'essentiel de l'actualité